si vous consommez quoi que ce soit
pendant votre séjour ici vous serez
immédiatement exclu connaissent assez
riant c'est juste pour dormir au début
ça va pas que tuer non plus un règlement
c'est la dernière fois que je te dis
vous êtes nouvelle donc vous êtes
arrivée celle ce soir après ça change
tous les jours
huit ans et la remise vous apportez les
piquets devant les places au sol et vous
enfoncés dans la terre ne s'est pas
difficile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas envie de mes parents voient ici
jeu qui me va bien ok ça sera un peu
comme un nouveau départ
notre amitié on sait comme la cab vous
voyez pas là on est en train de fuir
c'est maintenant que vous préparez votre
futur ça se fait pas avec une béquille
on boit de complètement l'une sans
l'autre c'est ça
[Musique]
depuis le début vous êtes en résistance
vous pouvez pu rester dans ce sens qu'il
met dehors en marche et elle sait très
bien
[Musique]
aidez moi juste la trouver dans quelque
chose n'importe quoi jouons un autre
pour deux c'est carrément impossible je
me débrouillerai je ferai rien sans
droits je sais pas si je vous rends
service
tu crois que ça va finir comment tu vois
pas qu'ils ont gagné tous
ils ont raison de l'agression restent
toutes les deux
commentant il faut faire semblant en
fait je fais tout comme il faut faire et
ça change rien je ressens rien
tout va aller
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]